THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Thanks guys.
I'm really excited to be here.
So I'm just going to do a
little--I'm going to talk
a little bit about
one title I have,
which was bestowed
on me by Vice,
which is a masculinity expert.
It's kind of
tongue-in-cheek, but I
think it's a great way to
start a larger conversation
about gender that I'm
really interesting in having
all the time.
So, in 2013, I began
writing a column for Vice.
And it was funny, that
they were calling me
a masculinity expert,
because I've only
been a man in the
literal sense of being
on testosterone for
about three years.
And now I give talks
about masculinity all
over the country.
And I'm writing a new
book based on a column
I'm writing for the
"Pacific Standard."
And I don't know what
the book will be called,
but the column's called
"The American Man."
So I guess the first question
is, how did this happen?
How did I become a masculinity
expert in four years or less?
So to me, in many
ways, the story
starts with the book,
"Man Alive," which
I began writing in 2010,
but sort of the narrative
started way before that.
And how I became a man and a
masculinity expert in general,
is really the story of
how I became myself.
So that's where
I'd like to start.
So, I'm going to read you guys
a little bit from the book.
And I'll read a little
bit more in a few minutes.
And then we'll take
questions in a little bit
because I think questions
are much more fun.
And I want to know
who you all are
and why you're here,
which is the most
interesting thing to me.
So this is the
prologue of book, which
I think sets us
up pretty nicely.
"South Carolina.
August 2010.
29 years old.
What makes a man?
It's not that I haven't studied
them, their sinew, their slang,
their beautiful bristle.
But before I was held at
gunpoint on a cold April day,
I couldn't have told you.
A real man, a family man,
the Marlboro man, man up,
the man in the mirror.
I loved that Michael
Jackson song growing up,
used to forget my girl hips.
Used to sing it to my best
imagination of myself.
What makes a man?
The need to know led me
to my father's hometown
in hot, damp South Carolina.
The story starts
there because that's
where I went when I
could no longer afford
to leave the question alone.
To let it rear up
every few years
when I'd had too much
to drink and it was just
me and my reflection
and my hungry ghosts.
And so I steered my
rental through the swampy
south with my cap pulled low.
I had that teen
boy swagger, scars
like smiles across
my chest, and a body
I was just beginning to love.
But the story also
begins the night
I almost died, back in
April of 2010, and in 1985,
when my father became a
monster, and in 1990 when
my mom found out he was one.
Men, she'd said then.
And I learned to say it the
same way, a lemon in my mouth.
In South Carolina,
I could smell it
through my open window,
alligators and secrets,
the embers of Sherman's
March, the Ku Klux Klan,
my father's farm burning.
It smelled like my animal
fear and the spicy deodorant
I used to cover it.
Men, I thought with
that old bitterness.
But I already knew
my body was shifting.
In fact, that's why I was there.
A good man is hard to find.
The windshield blurred, the road
was inky, the rain, biblical.
The cheap motel off the highway
seemed like not such a hot idea
after I passed my fifth
gun racked pickup.
But there wasn't
any turning back.
Once a body's in motion,
it stays in motion.
My mom's a physicist.
She told me that.
The truth is, this
is a ghost story.
No, this is an adventure story.
This is an adventure story
about how I quit being a ghost."
So that's where it starts, 2010.
A little background.
This was before my transition.
I looked very masculine.
And in April of that year.
I was mugged from behind
and held execution-style
at gunpoint, by this man,
George Huggins, who went on
to actually shoot two other men
and kill one in the process.
So what was really
interesting about this for me,
was that I was released when I
spoke, when my voice came out
of my mouth.
Up until that
point, I don't think
that George Huggins
realized that I wasn't male.
And what was really
amazing to me,
was that that actually set
me on this whole story,
that it turned around my ideas
of what gender sort of meant
and it set me free
in a lot of ways.
And I was really
interested in that,
which is where the
book came from.
Because I got to run away.
And it gave me not
just a new angle on,
not just my body, but
also my story in general.
And obviously there's a
Google connection here.
So 2011, I guess at this
point I was asking myself
a lot of questions
about like, if it's
possible to be a good man.
I was revisiting, by doing that,
my examples of like, the worst
examples of masculinity,
because that
was sort of what was
holding me up in general.
And I meant, in a lot of
ways, the worst examples
were my father, which
I know a lot of men
can relate to that, and also of
course, Mr. Huggins, himself.
And what I was really
interested in too,
was just exploring the
universals of masculinity.
I didn't ever think of
myself as just a trans man,
having to figure out
what it is to be trans.
I thought of myself
as a man, figuring out
what it is to be a man,
which I think a lot of men
really struggle with
what that really means.
So I'll read you a little
bit more from the book,
just to give you a little
more context of what
that looked like.
You know, I'm an
artist, so I don't never
pretend to speak on
anybody else's behalf.
I'm not speaking on behalf
of the trans community
or anything.
But I think when we can
listen to one person story,
we learn a lot about
all of our stories.
"I could tell that
Dad charmed people.
Everyone gravitated to his
lilting southern accent,
his aw shucks smile,
and his good manners.
He seemed useful,
refined, and so
it was easy to overlook
his silver halo,
forget he was in his
'50s, way older than Mom.
But people can hold their true
selves at bay for only so long.
I knew that from Batman.
Today, he looked
worn out, exposed,
waiting for us in
a leather chair,
his remaining hair unkempt,
gray stubble crowding his face.
His knuckles were thick,
swollen as an old man's, and he
wore his exercise clothes, a
gray tracksuit, coffee-stained.
He looked like the
raggedy dog he once
shot in the butt with
a BB gun for crossing
onto our property
one too many times.
"What are you doing," Mom
had said on the sunny porch
that afternoon a
few years before,
her voice laced with alarm.
Maybe she'd never
seen that side of him.
But I knew it
intimately and how he'd
look when he turned
around, smiling
that dumb, menacing smile.
Of course, one man
can become another.
Where two sides meet, comes
the potential for ghosts.
Dissonance smears,
rips in the story.
It was only his ass, he'd
said, in that gentle accent,
unloading the BBs
carefully into his palm.
Just teaching him a lesson.
The dog never did come back.
Where I grew up in
Western Pennsylvania,
deer were hunted to keep
the population down.
still we put out salt
licks and watched
whole families wander by.
I thought I could open
the door and approach them
as long as I moved
slowly enough.
They'd lock eyes with me, ears
pricked, stuck, as if stopped
by time.
I'd get closer and closer,
five yards, four, three.
I'd reach a hand out greedily,
and like magic, their eyes
would pop open a little, the
body hunching into themselves.
Then, always, they'd spring
awake and bound away, big
and graceful, alive.
There was an invisible
line, a wire I'd trip,
and it was different each
time, four yards two.
Every body has a
different threshold,
but we all know how
to run eventually.
Most people don't realize that.
We never forget how to escape."
So once I was convinced
that there was a way
to meet a good man, that's when
I began my transition in 2011.
So I was 30 years
old at the time.
And because I'm a writer
and I work in media,
one thing that I was
really interested in was I
didn't see my story anywhere.
Not just my story of like, what
is to be a trans man, but again
the kind of man I wanted to be.
I never felt very
connected to the idea being
born in the wrong
body, which was
the narrative that
was out there.
It's hard to imagine this
was just a few years ago.
But really, if you saw any
stories about a trans person
in media, you were
seeing a story
about someone being
murdered, or you
were seeing these sort of like
soft, heart-wrenching stories
about how people were
trapped in their bodies
and they just
needed to transition
and make their
lives better so they
could be in a different
body and then everything
was perfect after that.
I just didn't really relate
to either of those narratives.
So what I thought a lot about
was, like I was becoming
a man, what I was
really becoming
was an intentional human being.
And since I didn't
see my story anywhere,
I just started writing it.
So I wrote stories for "Salon"
and "The Atlantic" and "Vice"
and the "New York Times."
I just wanted to write
myself into existence.
I really believe that
the most violent thing
we can do each other is make
each other, other, pretend
that an experience that's
human that any one of us
is experiencing is
somehow really radically
different than an experience
another of us could have.
And I found that very, very
violent and very upsetting.
So my goal from the very
beginning has been to say,
this is my particular story,
but it's a story any of us
could have.
I'm a universalist
and I really think
in a lot of ways my transition
wasn't about female to male,
that's really simple.
I think it was about
young adult to adult,
which I think most
people can relate to.
And I'm the kind of person who
sees similarities everywhere.
I mean, when I
was transitioning,
I related most to
pregnant women.
I lived in New England.
I didn't have a trans community.
So I spent a lot
of time with women
who were having a lot
of hormonal changes
and who were wondering who they
were going to be once they had
their baby and what this
identity would mean for them.
And those were the people
I was connecting to most.
So my work has always
been about that.
So that's what I
was doing in 2012.
Also, I was writing this column
called "The Self-Made Man,"
which I started when I was a
few months on testosterone,
because I didn't
have the community,
and I didn't see
myself anywhere.
And I've been lucky enough to
write it for the last two years
now.
And I think in a
lot of ways, this
was capturing the big
questions in my book
and just my life in general.
It opens, this is
the very first one,
"What does it mean to be a man?
To me it means a lot
and nothing at all.
It means I'm 30 years
old and I love my body.
It means that men look at me
and see an ally or a threat.
It means nothing
is what it seems,
that none of us can look at
another and know what's in this
pants or his heart, and
that surprise is inevitable,
but how you react to
it is who you are. "
And that's a lot of like,
the question I was asking
and really, I guess I
knew the answer all along.
So by last year, 2013, I
was asking and answering
this question all over
the place and it's sort of
moved on to a
different question.
Instead of what
makes a man, I was
asking, how do we become
more than what's sold to us.
Meaning, we have
an understanding
what masculinity
means, but where
do we get that understanding?
I think, my experience is
that gender is kind of innate.
I think that we, in a
lot of ways, are born,
at least having
some understanding
of who we are in the world.
But the way that we
embody that gender,
is something that we have
a lot of choice around.
So I wasn't ever
interested in specifically
writing about the
trans experience.
But I was interested in writing
about the male experience
and the human experience.
And I think gender's just
one very powerful dimension
of identity, and just a way for
me personally to examine that.
So I think in the end, when I
was asking the question of what
makes a man, what I really meant
was, what makes a good man.
And I spent a lot of time
talking to men about gender,
because I think a
lot of men don't even
realize they have one,
which is basically
the definition of privilege, is
to move in the world thinking
that something is invisible,
when really it's not at all.
So being able to make it
visible is a really cool,
important thing that, hopefully,
I get to do for people.
And I also think with privilege
comes a lot of responsibility.
And that's where being
a good man comes in.
There's a lot of toxic
ideas about masculinity
out there in the world.
And there's a way to be very
healthy in your masculinity.
And that's something
that I think a lot about.
And I think the
first step is just
understanding that if you can
see it, you can change it.
For one thing, I know I'm
treated very differently.
I do a lot of talks to
people about workspace stuff,
about sexism at work
because I'm treated
very differently in a male body
that in my previous body, which
wasn't female actually.
I would say it was
more a queer body.
So the way people reacted
to me, was very different
than the way people
react to me now.
I'm given a lot more room
and a lot more respect.
People listen to me more.
And I spend a lot
of time thinking
about how different bodies
are treated in space
and how, as a person in a
leadership role in media,
I can make sure that
people who are male,
in the sort of passing male way
that I am, especially straight
white men, we make
more room for people
who are not those bodies.
And again.
I think a lot it's just
having some intention,
just having some
awareness about,
if you're lucky enough to be
in a body that has privilege
in this world, how do
you operate in such a way
to make room for everyone else.
So, now today, 2014,
I write this column,
like I said, "The American
Man" for "Pacific Standard,"
and basically, it's a broad
survey of masculinity, really
white American masculinity.
And I go to a bunch of places,
like I went to a boxing gym.
I've been to a bath house.
I'm going to frats.
And basically just
reporting back gonzo style.
So this is a little
excerpt from one
about going to a boxing gym.
But I think that
the main point is
that, when I think about being
a man today, what I'm thinking
about being, is being so much
more than just a man moving
in space, but being an
intentional human being.
And again, just
making that visible.
So, finally, I think now
where I'm at in 2014,
thinking about what being
an expert about being a man
is, what I think we, all
people who are men are,
it just is sort of,
there's a koan in Zen,
"Zen Mind, Beginner's Mind."
Basically, I don't
know if anybody here
is familiar with this koan,
but I find it very useful.
Which is basically,
that to be an expert
is to have a very
closed mind when
you think you know everything.
But to be a beginner,
that's where
real creativity and
expertise comes from.
So I think, in a lot of ways,
my journey into masculinity
was one of a beginner's mind.
And what I've come
up with is my answer.
What makes a man
is, like I said,
I think gender in a
lot of ways is innate.
I think, especially
in queer circles,
there's an idea that
gender is performance.
And maybe so, but I
think that doesn't quite
explain my experience.
Like, I knew I was a
guy, what does that mean?
At the other end
of it, the paradox
is that I also think
it's really constructive.
I think we have a lot of
choice about what kind of men
and women and everything else
we want to be in the world.
So I think a man, and a good man
specifically, is intentional.
And I think a good
man makes himself.
And so that's what I
found in my journey.
I'm happy to take questions.
I guess my only caveat that
I tend to give about this is
just, I love Q&As.
I really would love to
answer any questions.
Any question you
ask me is one you'd
have to be willing
to answer yourself.
I've only had to use
that a couple of times.
So does anybody have
anything they want to ask me?
Or any statements
about, I don't know
masculinity or
maleness or queerness.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You
talked a little bit
about how you were
treated very differently
before your transition.
Could you talk a little bit
more about what happened?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
So I think I didn't know
I was treated differently.
Because I didn't
have a really typical
feminine, female presentation.
I think a lot of women who are
in the world in a feminine way,
are very aware of
that difference
because we talk about it a lot.
But I was very
queer and masculine,
which is a different thing.
But still, at the
end of the day,
I think I didn't read
as male in that way.
So again, I don't think
there is one way that I
was being treated
that I could pinpoint.
But I do know that
suddenly, when
I'm in spaces like
work meetings,
people pay more attention
to what I have to say.
I have a lower voice
and I talk lower.
I'm actually harder to
hear, but people are quiet
and they lean in
and they listen.
And generally, I
think that women
are socialized in a lot of ways
to sort of hang back or be very
conscientious about what
everyone else is saying around
them.
and men really aren't.
And so I really
was aware of that
very quickly, that
me being male,
with a male voice in a
male space, if I spoke,
everyone would turn to
me and I was much more
aggressive about communicating.
Whereas women in the
same spaces or people
who were gender nonconforming
in the same spaces
might not be as
aggressive or emboldened.
And I was noticing that a lot.
I was working at this place
called PolicyMic, now Mic,
where we had a very
young staff and I
was managing editor there.
So I worked really
hard when I was there
to try to make a lot of room
for women in the space to speak.
Because again, I don't
think any of this
is an intentional sexism.
I think it's actually just
socialized differences and then
lack of awareness.
And the more we make
something visible,
the more it becomes a thing that
people are conscientious about.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when
you go and talk
to men about being [INAUDIBLE]
especially when they may not
see their privlege, et cetera,
what are the kinds of road
blocks that you find that
when you come to somebody,
what's the first thing where
they sort of push back?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
I've actually found that it's
a lot more helpful to ask
questions than it is, I
think-- I've actually talked
to a lot of women who say,
I'm very frustrated because I
try to explain to my boyfriend
what privilege means,
and he doesn't get it.
Because he's saying, well,
I've had a hard life,
or this is my particular
life circumstance
and you're not really
making room for it.
That makes a lot of
sense because we're
interpersonal creatures.
But we also live in an
institutionalized world.
So being able to hold both at
once, and I think a lot of men
get very defensive.
Because they think, I'm
trying to be a good guy here.
Why are you attacking
me or why am I
having to hold the weight of
every male who ever has existed
or whatever.
But of course, that is part of
the privilege of being male,
is you have to hold the
weight of every man who
has ever existed before you.
On the other hand, I
think a lot of times,
men want to engage this
with this question,
in my experience.
They actually
really want to live
in a world that's not
as constraining to them.
Sexism hurts men too.
So a way around,
sort of just being
in a weird kind of
defensive space with people,
is to say, well,
what is masculinity?
What do you mean when you say
that you feel like you can only
act this way or when you say
this thing about women, what
are you actually
saying right now?
Like, just sort of opening
up to have a conversation
has been a really
easy way to dig
into what's really
troubling for everybody.
Which is that we're in
these very rigid spaces
culturally, that are
hurting all of us.
So my biggest roadblock is
that men, in my experience,
when they feel on the defensive,
because they feel like they're
having to be responsive in a way
that is was like, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
I'm not doing anything wrong.
That is the same way as
like open communication
with a couple where
it's like, I'm
feeling this way when you do x.
It so much easier to
sort of come at it
from a more assuming
the best kind of place.
And again, most men I talk to
are actually very responsive.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We live in a
world where being male
is, in some ways, the default.
Like, what you were
alluding to, right?
And we have the privilege of
not thinking about gender.
So having sort of seen things
from both outside and within,
do you, like, have a-- you
tend to perceive that more
and see, oh, I'm being
privileged in this situation I
know you mentioned that
people pay attention
to you at meetings and
stuff, but even if it's not
interpersonal
interactions, do you see it
in things like media?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
I think so.
I mean, I think the great
advantage of having not lived
in a male body until
this point, and in one
that I would very easily
be able to sort of just
fade into the woodwork
and like, relax about,
is that suddenly
I am the default.
And I think, just
like white people
have the need to work on
being aware that being white
is the default, I think men
need to be aware that being male
is the default.
And absolutely, I notice it.
I mean, it's pretty
jarring, actually,
to go from especially
having a queer body,
where I really didn't
fit into any gender box,
to being in a situation
where, when I leave my house
and walk down the street, a
million things are happening
because I'm a white male who
is straight in the world.
And I never forget that.
Because to me, that
dissonance is really
interesting and
important and says a lot
about what is to be just
a person in the world.
But also because I think
if I forgot that, then I
would be the kind of
person, the kind of man,
I didn't want to be
in the first place.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thomas, this
year and last year,
there just seems a
trans understanding
[INAUDIBLE] already complicated,
but just understanding
and awareness, I
guess. [INAUDIBLE]
but so much has happened in
a year, in a year and a half,
I've seen a reflection in
your writing of just looking
to the next year or
the next five years,
what are you excited about?
I just see it really changing
and I'm just curious kind of,
what you're looking forward to.
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
I really bet, I really
bet hard on a few things
for my own work.
We talked a little at the
beginning about about,
like in, 2010, when
I was first writing,
of 2011 really, about
being trans and being male.
There weren't any stories,
that were in mainstream media
anyway about this stuff,
except for kind of sad stories
or again, very like,
kind of essentialist,
very reductive stories,
that really, in my mind,
assumed the worst of
the non trans audience.
Like, the sort
of, oh, man, we've
really got to work hard to
help people understand this.
So trans people are
born in the wrong body.
OK.
Does that make sense?
And then we just
made this change.
And then, OK, now
we're like you.
So, whew.
Like, you know.
And I think a lot of that comes
from the gate-keeping medical
narrative too.
Like, where it's
like, to get hormones,
trans people throughout time--
and a lot of trans people
relate to that narrative,
so that's fine.
But trans people
throughout time,
have had, since hormones
have been available,
have had to basically
go into doctor's offices
and say, you know, I feel
trapped in the wrong body.
I'm going to kill myself if
I don't make this change.
And then, therefore, that's
how you get your hormones.
So I think in the
last few years,
what's really changed is social
media and new media providing
these platforms for those
of us who are like, no,
that's not quite right.
It's more complicated.
It's nuanced.
To write those stories, but also
provided like room for people
to meet us there.
I think social media
really encourages
connection and
proliferation of stories
that connect and
resonate with people.
And I think being part of
that has been really exciting,
because what I bet on was that
that was true, that diversity
and narratives would
actually make a difference.
And that people
would meet me where
I was, if I just
expected them to.
And that's been true
in my experience.
And I feel like that's
what we're seeing now,
with trans visibility in media.
And then of course, there's been
pop cultural representations
like "Orange is the
New Black," and now
"Transparent," where
we're just seeing
more nuanced stories
about trans lives.
So I'm excited that I think
that's going to continue.
And I think the conversation's
become much more
about what do trans people have
to say about gender broadly,
rather than, wow, isn't it
so weird that some people are
trapped in the wrong body and
now they find their new body
and it's, woof, like that
was a real hard thing
to think about for five minutes.
Now I feel like people are
like, what's my gender?
And what does gender mean?
And you know,
especially with the rise
of feminism in a
pop culture way,
I think we're all talking about
gender more, which is great.
And millennials, I
think specifically,
are really interested in
gender, which is also great.
So I think we're just in a very
amazing watershed moment, where
all these things are combining.
I think that's
going to continue.
What I'm excited to see
more of is policy changes,
especially for the more
marginalized among us.
I think always,
people get forgotten
in these kinds of moments.
And I think
especially trans women
of color, who are the
most adversely affected
by transphobia.
I'm hoping more and more
that those folks are
going to get more
protections and that we're
going to be more conscientious
about the violence that's still
happening in these communities.
That's my hope.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You had
mentioned going
into male dominated
environments,
such as frat
houses, bath houses.
Do you ever reveal
your background
before going into
that environment?
Do you find that skews
the overall experience
or do you just sit
back and watch see--
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
--what happens.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
I think passing
is a really interesting concept.
And I think we're all passing.
I mean, again my general
orientation in life
is seeing the universal.
So I think passing is
something I never thought about
until I transitioned.
And a lot of people feel really
uncomfortable with that word,
which I totally understand.
But I also feel
like over time I've
realized that we're all
passing all the time.
I mean, there's a way that
we're passing at work.
We're all passing in
this room, that we're all
passing with out families, that
we're passing in the street.
And there's just--
it's really hard
to be a fully-- every dimension
of yourself in every space.
That being said, this project
specifically, the American Man
project, is about being gonzo,
which is how I think of it.
I'm really interested in how
men react to men without sort
of knowing that there's
something more dynamic going on
in my background.
And so no, in this
particular case,
I don't make a point of it.
I'm really Google-able.
You can easily
find out everything
you need to know about my
life by looking me up online.
So it's certainly not a secret.
But I try as much as
possible to experiment
with being in homo
social male spaces,
and reflecting back
what that really means.
And usually it's
really surprising.
I think a lot of the things
you expect, of course,
tend to be true.
But I'm often pleasantly
surprised in male spaces.
I've had so many moments in
like the locker room, hearing
some super vulnerable
conversation between two dudes
about a woman who's broken
somebody's heart or whatever.
It's really next level and
there's sort of fragility
there that I find
really interesting.
So I don't know.
Yeah, I don't make
a point to, I guess,
reveal that I'm trans before
I hang out in those spaces.
Though I think it would be
interesting to be in a space
where someone were
to know and how
that might affect the situation.
Probably that will
happen at some point.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Have you been exploring both
sort of traditionally straight
spaces and traditionally
queer spaces for men?
And what kinds of
things do you see a--
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: --difference.
Yeah.
So, so far I've been
to a gay bathhouse,
which was really interesting.
What I was most
interested in, what
I've been most interested
in in this project
is things that scare me as
a man and as a trans man
specifically.
So I was very afraid to
be in a gay bath house,
because I felt like my
physio-- my biology,
my body physically might be sort
of revealing in some way that
would be scary.
And that really wasn't true.
And that was really interesting.
And also-- that one's online.
You can read it.
But basically, it was a
tough moment in my life,
where my mom was very
ill and I hadn't really
figured out a way to process it.
And actually being in this
space with a bunch of guys
who were cruising each other
and doing whatever else.
But also a lot of
Hasidic guys were
at the Russian Turkish
baths down in-- Yeah.
So it was like all
kinds of folks.
And like coexisting together
in this really interesting way,
these orthodox Jews and
then these gay guys,
who were just there
to cruise at 10:00
AM on a Sunday morning and me.
And so it ended up being a
really beautiful experience,
because it was just yet another
lesson that you just show up
and you're yourself, and
however you are in that moment,
there's room.
And I was able to
process a lot of feelings
actually in that moment.
So that's been--
Yeah, I mean I don't
think that there's some grand
statement I could make about,
like gay men are
different in this way
and straight men are
different in this way.
I don't think so at all.
But I think being able to
move in these different worlds
and sort of reflecting
back in every moment, what
those worlds look like has
been a really cool process.
The boxing story, actually,
is a lot about class.
Because I went to
this amateur boxing
gym where a lot of
Wall Street guys
were taking boxing lessons.
And then also all of
these prize fighting
dudes who are
putting their bodies
on the line for like $500
are working really hard
to try to make that happen.
And there was a lot
of class tension
in those spaces
between the men there.
So I think it's like there's
all these intersections
of different identities
happening at the same time.
And maybe more than most people,
I'm very conscious of that
and that's why I try
and reflect back.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm kind
of like struggling
to understand how to
like be intentional
and to make myself I guess
I'm struggling to understand
like how to achieve
those things.
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: It's like
a life process, I think.
Yeah.
Well, that's why I really think
like the first-- the thing
I was most afraid of and the
reason I wrote this book was
that these sort of terrible
definitions of being male
were the only option.
So that's why, in
a lot of ways, why
I didn't transition
until so late in my life.
I was really trying to be
like a masculine person,
because that was
a way to be what
I felt like I was without having
to actually move in the world
as a man, which felt
really scary to me.
Because I just had such negative
associations with being male.
And so much of my
personal process
was about sort of
realizing, I don't
have to be just the things
that are sold to me.
I don't have to
take on this role
just because somebody says,
this is what men do or don't do.
And maybe-- and
for me a lot of it
was like mining what
was uncomfortable
or what didn't feel right,
and saying, you know,
I'm not going to do it this way.
And it's not so simple.
It wasn't like, let me eschew
all symbols of masculinity.
There are things about being
a man and being in a male body
and being masculine
that I really like.
But it's more just
that I review them.
And when something comes up
and makes me uncomfortable,
I sit with it for a minute.
And I'm like, well,
what is making
uncomfortable about this?
I think I'm much more
nurturing now that I'm male.
Because the way that I feel
about being nurturing as
a man feels really good to me.
And it's a different
way of-- that way
of being nurturing, being
protective and doing things
to care for people in a way
that's much more sort of hands
on, that feels
really good to me.
I've opted in to that.
But I won't opt in
to other aspects
of what being masculine
in our culture
means that make me
feel uncomfortable.
Like, I'm not going be
disrespectful to women
because that asserts
my masculinity somehow
to other men.
So I think it's a lot about
when something comes up
that doesn't feel good,
sort of figuring out, well,
what is that and why
doesn't it feel good and do
I want to really be that
and that sort of thing.
And actually listening a
lot to women specifically,
because I think we're having
a lot of conversations
in our culture right
now about cat calling
and what it's like at work
and leaning in or whatever.
And why do we have to lean in?
Or can women have it all?
And it's like, those questions
aren't irrelevant to men
because we're all participating
in the same dynamic.
So being willing to look at
something just because it makes
you a better person, not
just because it's like, oh,
I might want to help out
my girlfriend or my mom
or my sister or whatever,
by thinking about this.
So that's where I would start.
But a lot of it's just,
again, making the fact
that men have a gender
a visible thing.
Because then women for years,
because of feminism, have,
I think, really had a way to
engage with the idea of gender.
Like, if a woman wants to
wear really feminine clothes
and dress up and whatever and
she wants to opt into that
to go to work one
day, maybe she's
making a really conscious
feminist choice to do that.
I think men haven't had
the same thoughts around,
well, do I want to be whatever.
Do I want to take
boxing classes?
Why?
Whatever I'm doing, is it for
a reason that feels good to me?
Or am I choosing consciously to
do this thing because I want to
or am I just doing it
because I'm supposed to
and actually it's
really constricting
and maybe even harmful
to other people.
So that's where I started.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So my assistant
had a baby some months ago.
And when I told
people about it, they
would ask, the first thing
they would always ask,
was it a boy or girl.
And it always annoyed
me because that is not
the most important thing.
And so I wouldn't
tell them and I
noticed it would
drive them crazy.
And they would not stop asking.
So, of course, the
more this happened,
the less I wanted to tell them.
I was wondering if you
had any thoughts on this,
like the really strong
gender socialization.
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
Isn't it so interesting
that what we're really asking
is, what kind of person
is this person going to be.
like we can somehow, by
knowing if the person's born
with one body or another body.
I agree that it's a
really troubling thing.
I really like when parents
don't find out or wait.
But I also think,
like all things,
there's sort of a-- I think
it's overly idealistic to assume
we won't put expectations on
our children or on each other,
based on what gender
we think a person is.
I think, of course, we do.
Life is complicated and it's a
way we make sense of the world.
And these are
systems of operating.
Again, I think it
goes back to like,
is there a way to
integrate and to understand
that this is a paradox.
Where on one hand,
gender is probably
pretty innate for most
of us, and for all of us.
And most of us
are born in a body
that we don't want to change.
But even so, we need
to operate in a way
that we understand the cultural
and institutional expectations
that come along
with those bodies.
And it's very
restricting to all of us
when we assume that because
somebody looks one way,
therefore everything about
them is going to be this way.
So I guess to me, there's
not some simple solution
of like well, if we just
raise our children agendered,
then somehow that will
solve our problems.
I think probably not.
I think probably the
best thing we can do
is teach our kids that gender
is complex and nuanced.
And there's no way right
way to be and encourage
them to just be themselves.
And model that for our
kids and for each other.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
That's really--
no one's asked me that.
It's a great question.
Thank you.
I think a lot of queer
people have a lot of tattoos,
and probably a lot
for the same reason.
It's a way to be in the world
in a way that feels intentional
and sort of claim
your body as your own
in a space where people
don't always understand it.
For me personally, as
just a human being,
I have found tattooing--
like ritual in general
is a very-- it's a way for
me to operate culturally,
so that the world
makes sense to me.
These tattoos are
a lion and a lamb
and I got them in
the last six months.
And it was a lot for me
about a few different things.
One was feeling secure
enough professionally
to get "jobs stoppers," which
I always promised myself
I would do to mark that.
And also like, the idea
of the lion and the lamb,
which, I don't know,
ironically actually,
this is not in the story.
I don't think it's a
lion and lamb at all,
I've later found out.
It's a lamb and like a fox
or something in the Bible.
But just the concept,
I guess, that
like we need to integrate
both parts of ourselves,
our fierceness
and our gentleness
in order to operate
in a fully human way.
I really liked that.
And so every sort
of moment of my life
that I've had some sort of big
realization about the person I
am in the world, I usually mark
it with some sort of tattoo.
And I find the ritual of
that very-- it's a great way
to mark time.
You know, time
isn't linear anyway.
We all know that.
So how do we mark our
lives in a way that
contains them in some way and
there's a story behind it.
The best part about writing this
book, really, was that like,
I got to not only assert
my identity in a world that
didn't always
understand it, but also
to assert my understanding of
just the way life operates.
It's a book that really--
time is kind of like always
in a vortex.
And I think that's how memory
works and how life works.
We are organized much more
thematically than we think
and much less in a
way that's linear.
It's less spatial,
it's more thematic.
So in a lot of ways,
I think that's just
tattooing, writing a
book, being an artist
in any way is about being
able to operate in that realm.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any comments
about non-standard genders?
Non cis or [INAUDIBLE] female?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
I mean, what are you
really asking me?
AUDIENCE: I'm inviting you
to say something about that.
I don't have an actual question.
How one could
construct an identity
as [INAUDIBLE] or whatever.
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
I mean I think gender
is complex and nuanced.
And we all-- I really
believe there's
something innate to gender,
which is so interesting to me
anyway.
Because I came of age
in the queer '90s,
where it's was very
like, being post gender
was kind of-- that
was the big idea.
And I spent a lot of time
trying to be post gender
and it just didn't
work for me personally.
I really felt like I had
a gender and it was male.
And that was complicated.
But I think a lot of people are
innately in some other space
with that.
And I think that's really
cool and important too.
And that no gender
is obviously being
able to pass as male in a male
body is really a lot easier.
And again, that goes
back to the privilege
and being able to
pass in a lot of ways
as a woman in a female
body is really easy too
in a different way with
[INAUDIBLE] sexism.
So we're really privileged in
those ways and the people who
are not conforming aren't.
So just in the same
way that I think
we need to make space
for other stories,
like about trans
bodies, we certainly
make space for people's
gender identities
that aren't as conforming
to those standards.
I mean gender is a spectrum.
We all know that.
So I guess the only
thing I have to say
about it is that
those are really
important identities too.
Just doesn't happen to be mine.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's next
for your own [INAUDIBLE]?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
I think I really
love that I can change
the conversation
to be more than
about being trans.
Like, I think early on-- and
it just sort of parallels
my own life.
I really was interested in
being trans because that's
what I was operating
and operating
from a place of thinking
about it all the time
in the first couple of
years of my transition.
And over time, I've realized
that, just like my body,
in the world isn't
read as a trans body,
my interest in the
world is much more about
what does it mean
to be a male body.
And so, I continue
to, at least for now,
really be interested
in that question
and thinking about
how being male
affects the space around
me and vice versa.
So I think in my
construction, I'm
still constructing my male
self and being the kind of man
I want to be, not necessarily
the kind of trans man
I want to be, though
that's clearly related.
And so being able to talk to
men and ask these questions
and be in male spaces
and bring this stuff up,
is still something I'm
negotiating and figuring out
how to do well.
And I want to keep doing
it until I nail it,
so probably for the
rest of my life.
Anything else you guys?
This is such a great group.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] question.
I remember being 17 and getting
facial hair for the first time.
I'm thinking is this cool?
Is this annoying?
It literally took
me years to decide
if I wanted to be clean
shaven or have a beard.
I imagine you must have
gone through the same things
with a slightly
different twist on it.
What was that like?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: I mean so
every Halloween until this one,
well, not until this
one, until the last few,
I always was
something where I got
to have a fake beard,
like a mascara beard.
I was really committed
to the beard situation.
So as soon as I was
on testosterone,
I immediately was trying to grow
a beard because that was like,
I didn't have a lot
of ideas about what
I want it to look like.
Its kind of an
interesting thing to be
like kind of reborn in a body
that you already live in.
And testosterone
especially is interesting
because it really
is just turning
on genes that already exist.
So like I really had a
man inside me literally.
And we all have, you
know, women and men,
female and male bodies
inside of our bodies, which
is interesting to think
about, at least to me.
So I had no idea what
my body would do,
and so I was worried
about not having a beard.
And also I was
worried about going
bald, which might still happen.
So like all men, I think those
are the two primary things
I was thinking about during
coming into adulthood.
But my process was
very accelerated.
So I was really excited
to try to grow a beard.
I think it's worked out OK.
I feel very lucky.
But yeah, for me,
that was something--
it was one small thing that
was really important to me.
A lot of other things-- people
have different things that
are important to them
that they are hoping
will happen for their
bodies, like we all have.
And that for me-- facial
hair was one for me
that I was really excited about.
But if I hadn't had
a beard, I would
lived, like all guys
who can't grow beards.
You obviously picked to
go with the beard route
and it worked out well for you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
Other questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Have you felt
that being on testoterone
has changed anything
about who you
are as a person,
your personality?
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE:
I think that that's
a really interesting question.
I think about a lot.
I think it's extremely hard
to separate all of this stuff
from each other.
I mean, in the years since
I've been on testosterone,
I've moved to New
York from New England.
I ended a very
long relationship.
I had a lot of things
happen in my career.
I mean, so many
things have happened.
And I really became an adult.
So it's really hard for me to
know, well, this part of it
came from testosterone and
this part of it-- I don't know.
I do think that-- I do think
hormones affect our bodies.
And I do think that there
are ways for me personally
that testosterone's probably
affected how I behave.
It's just really hard
to know exactly what.
And also it's like
probably, yes.
Probably for example, I
probably am more assertive.
On the other hand,
am I more assertive
because I'm on testosterone
or because people expect me
to be more assertive
or am I because I'm
rewarded for being assertive
in ways I wasn't before?
I just don't know the answer.
I think my relationship
certainly with like--
and I've heard a
lot of people talk
about this, with
crying, is different.
It's harder for me to
cry, though I still can.
But it's just little bit
more difficult to do,
like literally physically.
Like I feel like I have to
cry and I can't sometimes.
I've had to relearn how,
which is interesting.
And then when I do, it's way
more intense but way shorter.
So what is that?
I don't know.
I don't think that's social.
I think that's something
physical with my body,
but I can't figure out
exactly what's going on.
So, yes, a lot of
it, I don't know.
It's really hard to pull apart.
I definitely think,
my honest answer
is I am absolutely
positive there are ways
that I've been affected
by these hormones.
I just don't know what they are.
Any other question?
Cool.
Well, you guys
have been awesome.
This have been a
really great group.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks so much.
If there are other
questions, we still
have the room for a few minutes.
There are books in the back.
If you would like
to get them signed--
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: --now
is a good time.
THOMAS PAGE MCBEE: Please
feel free to buy a book it
if you like.
And thanks so much, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]